regardez ce que j'ai je vous ai gâtés
aujourd'hui on a une belle surprise ça
te pose le regard des
chiens bidouze chien milou ce pro et ça
c'est cool donc ce qu'on fait tout de
suite c'est qu'on va se regarder les
chiots mais deux sur le doubs ce procès
un homme boxing c'est une découverte et
puis en même temps on va lui coûter
quelques images on va aller dehors
regarder un petit peu la photo de la
vidéo et je suis super content parce que
j'ai préparé la vidéo j'ai la fiche
technique je sais tout vous allez voir
le touquet à saidal
regardez regardez regardez regardez ils
sont là ils sont à la ils sont là je les
ai juste avant le lancement jeu 13 euros
mouche sur cette vidéo c'est au moment
du lancement c'est une vidéo aujourd'hui
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
xiaomi chômage il m'a dit tiens monsieur
rehausseur de nouveaux smartphones est
ce que tu voudrais elle est présente à j
ai bien sûr qu'on va y aller on se
présente alors on a le 12 pro et on a le
12 qu'on a commencé par le 12 pro c'est
marrant parce que l'année dernière au
niveau des chiots muse il avait sorti un
chien au 1011 ainsi omis aux ultras
n'avait pas eu le modèle pro c'était
réservé à l'asie la série qui nous a
sorti un modèle pro est ce que pour
autant on aura un modèle ultra tout de
suite j'ai pas cette info regardez
qu'est ce qu'on a ici à on a déjà
quelques informations au niveau du
smartphone on voit qu'on a une triple
caméra 50 méga pixels donc ça c'est très
très cool on voit qu'on a quoi sa
dragonne oui john wang hao qui on le
savait on voit qu'on a un écran wqs des
plus dynamiques 120 hertz ça veut dire
qu'on va voir un taux de
rafraîchissement variable en fait entre
1 à 120 hertz ça c'est grâce à la
molette sert à sa technologie ltp au
regard des si vous le voyez bien la quad
speaker's quatre haut parleurs ça c'est
assez dingue parce qu'on avait
l'habitude d'avoir deux haut parleurs
j'avais beaucoup aimé l'expérience était
sur le chien ou mire le midi ce projet
avait adoré le dos à le trouver un point
- dernière mel avait quatre haut
parleurs avec harman kardon ça peut être
très cool et pionnat de la recharge
rapide 120 watts et du 50 watts son fils
enfin c'est très cool parce qu'on avait
vu avec le chien au 1011 des pros
l'année dernière la recherche 120 watts
et en 17 minutes c'était c'était assez
haut fourneau le bloc de charge 120
watts qui inclut intérieur donc ça c'est
aussi très très très cool on le voit la
regarder ça ça dépote on a ensuite
forcément 2 usb avère de l'usbc et puis
c'est tout quoi voilà tout ce qu'on a
ici alors regardez ensuite ça bon là
j'ai découvert mes tiroirs de 4,6 mme
gerekou petit dock on s'en fiche et le
smartphone
à j'aime bien j'avais déjà vu en photo
un mais j'aime bien ce côté matt se
touchent et extrêmement doux alors ça ça
a plusieurs intérêts déjà ça prend pas
de traces de doigts regardez là il ya
aucune trace de doigt il ya un côté très
premium le module photo si je laime bien
à la fois à ont dit à la fois un peu
ricklin là haut niveau vous voyez des
petites barres l'a très bien fait à ça
ça dépasse très légèrement ici mais les
deux autres ne dépasse pas donc je
trouve ça assez marrant assez bien fait
et plutôt jolie j'aime bien le design de
ce produit vraiment il ya un petit effet
sur chenilles au 1000 en effet un peu de
3d il ya un côté un peu de profondeur
c'est très très jolie donc ça c'est
court qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve ici alors
un grand classique les boutons de volume
le bouton pour l'allumer pour les
timbres on va retrouver ici et bien
d'autres tiroirs de quartier avec double
viennent aussi mme 5g un haut parleur là
on va retrouver ici à prise usb c'est de
ce côté-là rien sur le dessus de
l'infrarouge un très grand classique le
micro il est bien écrit si harman kardon
et si vous regardez c'est bien écrit ci
et l'autre par leurs qui est là alors on
annonce quatre haut parleurs on va voir
comment ça marche parce que je suis très
très curieux de voir ça donc ça
effectivement c'est le xiaomi 12 pro et
il me plaît beaucoup parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on voit arriver un
modèle un peu plus standard chez tommy
qui s'appelle 12 pro est pas le xiaomi
midouze trop on l'avait déjà vu avec la
gamme t mais là c'est la première fois
qu'on doit arriver ici donc ça c'est
plutôt cool et ça commence à raconter
une nouvelle histoire est ici on a le
modèle eh bien je dirais standard normal
le xiaomi 12 tout court a forcément un
petit peu moins que le modèle propre et
qui a l'air aussi vachement bien ingrate
en effet de voir là c'est pareil on a
quelques infos on a une caméra
principale de 50 méga pixels on voit
également qu'on a un ultra grand angle
et une télé macro et en gardant quelques
instances nos dragons 8 de première
génération pareil un écran 120 hertz
amoled hockey haut parleurs stéréos y en
a pas qu'à tirana 2 toujours avec un
mode kardon de la recharge rapide 67 loi
tepa de la 120 watts de la recharge sans
fil 50 watts et puis une batterie de
4500 clients paire eur aud quai sur le
papier ça me semble bien g
bloc de charge 60 7 watts qui est là
donc ça c'est cool également et puis le
smartphone et j'enrage tout
ça c'est une autre couleur alors ce qui
est intéressant à savoir c'est qu'en
fait vous avez les mêmes couleurs sur
les deux modèles saas et la couleur un
peu violer alors il ya quoi comme
couleur il ya le legris donc le gris
c'est celui que j'ai là là qui est très
très mat on a ce petit violet il existe
également une couleur bleue donc ça
c'est bien regarder j'adore ces deux
couleurs c'est très sympa aussi alors on
a exactement le même design en un peu
plus petits là le blog photo ne sort pas
sur les deux sur le premier y sort
pareil les boutons ici de volume et pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre carte sim ici
haut parleurs alors ça s'est inversé
tiens on va votre regardez vous avez un
tiroir de cartes sim la la il est là
haut parleurs haut parleurs à risque et
de ce côté-là absolument rien sur le
dessus toujours pareil de l'infrarouge
on voit un peu mieux harman kardon ici
là qui écrit voyez juste là l'infrarouge
et les haut-parleurs donc une aversion
de ce côté là et puis sinon plutôt sympa
plutôt millions donc avant d'aller un
peu plus loin je me prend cinq minutes
je configure jeu mais oui si je fais les
mises à jour et puis je vous raconte
tout ok alors je pensais que ça allait
durer cinq minutes ça dure un peu plus
de 4 gigas de mise à jour par téléphone
alors regardé deux smartphones vraiment
pas dire différence se ressent beaucoup
mais il y en a quand même un poil plus
petits voiliers ça c est le doux ça
c'est le 12 pro alors on va regarder
déjà un petit peu au niveau des
proportions au niveau du design c'est
vrai que alors le 12 forcément comme il
est plus petit va être plus léger 180
grammes le 12 l'autre il fait un peu
plus de 200 grammes on à 205 grammes
c'est qu'il est un peu plus lourd c'est
pas la différence de taille de batterie
mais le 12 preuve d'un peu plus lourd
alors le truc qui est intéressant c'est
que dans les deux cas on un verre
corning gorilla glass victime ce qui
vient le protéger donc ça c'est vraiment
chouette à l'avant bien évidemment on va
retrouver dans les deux cas un écran
amoled écran amoled fabriqué par samsung
ça c'est un chiot me qui nous le dit
dans les deux cas un taux de
rafraîchissement de sang versé ça aussi
c'est très très cool alors on peut venir
le voir ici en allant dans écran et en
venant effectivement dans taux
d'actualisation alors une masse en
automatique qu'est ce que ça va venir
faire un automatique et bien en fait ça
vous switch entre 1 à 120 hertz grâce à
techno ltp au alors le lte et p&o c'est
sûr que je lai sur le promets je sais
pas si je les sens avec des pincettes
mais a priori je pense que oui et en
plus j'ai un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 480 r ça ça raconte quoi ça
raconte que lorsque vous venez jouer à
des jeux et bien si vous n'allez pas
voir de latence à elle est extrêmement
rapidement c'est extrêmement réactif
donc ça veut dire que des gens ont un
smartphone qui est vachement bien en
termes d'affichage pour venir regarder
des films des séries pour venir jouer à
des jeux le taux d'échantillonnage
tactile est aussi élevé donc ça c'est
bien qu'on ait de la performance avec le
cendre aegon 8 de première génération
donc ça en termes de gaming on a
vraiment un package qui fonctionnent et
sont probablement après adam touquet
vachement intéressant regardez je veux
dire pousser la luminosité à fond d'un
côté et l'autre c'est marrant parce
qu'on dirait que le 12 et plus lumineux
que le pro alors que le prg ont ils
affichent mille litres et un pic à 1510
est ce que notre côté on a un pic à 1000
litres et c'est marrant parce que voyez
en les poussant tous les deux là j'ai
l'impression quand même que c'est le 12
qui est plus lumineux bon si peut-être
qu'une impression ça viendrait aussi de
mon éclairage ici donc il faudra venir
valider ça lors du test qu'on en
reparlera ultérieurement sera un test
indirectement donc je n'ai vous abonner
ce n'est pas déjà le cas petit bouton
rouge si les rouges c'est que vous
n'êtes pas abonné autre différence qui
est vraiment intéressante c'est que sur
le pro vous avez et résolution wqvga jeu
des plus regardées lorelei nos amis en
full hd plus mais en réalité vous le
passez en wqs des plus c'est à dire que
là on foule à dire plus de briller chez
en 2004 100 par 1080 et si je le passe
en wqs je n'ai plus eu à 3220 1400 ça
ajoute de la clarté a fait de voir si je
passe là c'est peut-être là où je vais
gagner un petit peu en clarté par
rapport à l'autre je me suis dit on
t'aime sombre tandis que sur le 12 mai
voyais je suis uniquement s qui joue
très très bien je peux pas bien changé
je suis sur un full hd + à 2400 par 1080
et alors regardez là donc on va voir la
différence rires oui j'aurais plus de
luminosité ici je vois pas vraiment la
différence bon ça effectivement une fois
de plus faute en faudra pendant le test
dans les deux cas dolby vision dans les
deux cas hdr vis plus alors le pro il
est certifié or la certification gelé là
j'ai noté c'est le sgs i-care display
grèce une certification au niveau de
votre écran ici et vous avez également
une certification pour lutter contre la
lumière bleue au niveau du 12 par contre
on sait pas qui l'a certifié voilà en
tout cas je suis au bout nous annonce
qu'il est certifié donc ça c'est bien
dans les deux cas un écran 20 deviennent
donc assez allongée et ça fonctionnera
et puis diagonale 6,73 pouces pour le
pro contre 6,28 pouces pour le chiot
midouze alors rien d'autre que je
voulais vraiment voir c'est toute la
partie audio allez on va se fixer
rapidement on va se mettre sur youtube
[Musique]
pas mal hein alors il ya un petit
déséquilibre par rapport à ce qu'on
avait sur le xiaomi à 10 pro vous avez
adoré mais c'est mieux que ce qu'on
avait en fait celui là il est un peu
plus médium sur le côté et crache un peu
plus celui là il a plus de grave un peu
plus de rondeur alors on me dit quatre
haut parleurs le mode de sortie il ya
peut-être quatre haut parleurs à
l'intérieur pour venir apporter
effectivement de la puissance nationale
et du locle à gelos cas ce que j'ai lu
jusqu'à avoir pas lui aussi là on voit
pas bien le disséquer mais par contre
toi ya une spatialisation est vrai que
l'expérience allait quand même super
cool pour venir écouter du contenu
multimédia c'est bien on va se faire le
même test sur l'autre non au bout
clients
après je pense que la vraie différence
qu'on va avoir entre les deux ça serait
vraiment à rire voir me dire disséquées
sur le pro ce qui est sûr c'est que vous
avez plus de graver plus de rondeur
alors on garde quand même les pieds sur
terre parce qu'on parle d'un smartphone
meilleure socialisation sur le 12 ça
fonctionne mais c'est un peu plus médium
et l'expérience comme ça va être un peu
moins cool au niveau de l'audio ce que
vous pouvez faire néanmoins ça veut dire
appéré un casque en bluetooth cinq
podiums dont sert parfaitement bien et
ça c'est cool et si vous avez des hauts
parleurs signé harman kardon et du dolby
atmos alors je vous le disais tout à
l'heure on a effectivement sur ses
smartphones un snapdragon nuit de
première génération le sam rigo nuit
jonone que je vous avais déjà présentée
lorsque j'étais hawai'i l'année dernière
d'ailleurs à ce moment là qualcomm avait
annoncé que le premier smartphone à
venir l'intégrer à sa serai xiaomi
regarder on les a ici alors il a déjà
été présenté en chine c'est la raison
pour laquelle il allait même petit peu
tard en europe la techno drame c'est de
l'alpi ddr5 la techno de stockage à
l'udaf et ce trois points qui ravit en
lecture et en écriture et puis surtout
sur le programme une batterie de 4600
milliampères heures tandis que sur le
show 1012 vous avez une batterie de 4500
bilan période y'a pas une grosse
différence envoyé au niveau de la
capacité de la batterie par contre ce
qui est intéressant et je vous le disais
sur le pro vous avez de la recharge
rapide 120 watts contre 67,3 de l'autre
côté dans les deux cas de la recharge
sans fil 50 watts et dans les deux cas
de la recharge inversée d'iwate s'ils
voulaient venir recharger une montre des
écouteurs tout ce que vous voulez après
il ya un autre truc intéressant c'est au
niveau la partie logicielle vous avez
mis waitress pour android 12 alors ça on
en reparlera ultérieurement parce qu'il
ya plein de choses à venir raconter
c'est super intéressant je pense qu'une
mise à jour aussi qui va arriver dans
les temps à venir mais bon 1013 ça
fonctionne bien on peut faire un pas mal
de choses on peut venir un personnalisés
et on peut avoir différents fonds
d'écran ça j'en reparlerai
ultérieurement donc une fois de plus
venez vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait puis toutes les intéresse aussi et
surtout c'est la partie photo alors
regardez là ya des choses qui sont assez
différentes sur le modèle pro vous avez
un capteur principal c'est 1,50
mégapixels si c'est un triptyque 50 50
50 50 50 méga pixels sans votre grand
angle qui ouvre à f 1.9 avec la techno 4
pixels en oc permettre de regrouper
plusieurs pixels pour sortir un gros
pixels de 2,4 micromètres donc ça c'est
plutôt bien captera plus de lumière en
faible luminosité c'est la fameuse
caméra sony scellier milk 707 sur vox
grand-angle votre grand temps de votre
grand angle je pense que c'est celui là
ici je peux vous dire de bêtises on a
une 50 méga pixels couvre f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision ne 115° et puis vous
avez un téléobjectif 50 méga pixels tout
bref 1.9 et c'est l'équivalent de 48 mm
tandis qu'à l'avant et c'est la même
caméra que vous allez avoir sur les deux
bien vous avez vous l'avez peuple a
montré là une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels
trouve rêve 2.45 akka technolog
allemands 4 pixels en hausse sauf que là
ça vous fait un gros pixels de 1,4
micromètres et puis sur le terrain le
plus petit modèle qui est quand même
assez gros mais qui en fera un petit peu
moins vous avez un capteur principal de
50 méga pixels qui ouvre à f 1.88 techno
4 pixels en un qui vous permet pas
d'avoir un gros pixels de 2,4
micromètres d'un gros pixels de 2
micromètres un petit peu moins ou
capturera un poil moins de lumière vous
avez un ultra grand temps de 13
mégapixels cuivre f 2.4 avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés puis vous avez télé
macro et les maquereaux c'est un 5
mégapixels équivalent de 5 mm et puis la
caméra de cette fille c'est exactement
là bas alors il ya différents modes qui
sont intéressants et que nous proposions
lui qu'on regardera ultérieurement lors
du test donc là c'est vraiment une
découverte on regarde ça rapidement on
active le suivi du mouvement qualité de
l'image
me au point sur le suivi de mouvement
mise au point sur le suivi des yeux
c'est un truc qui est vachement
intéressant c'est que voyez on va avoir
vraiment du tracking sur
le parti vidéo on pourra venir suivre
les mouvements reconnaîtra les yeux
quand je sais pas si l'aca va là où la
génère un peu surexposée là je sais pas
si ça va le faire je me rends pas compte
1 donc il faut vraiment que je le teste
que je prenne le temps à 6 jeux de
voiles et voiliers le petit carré au
niveau est-ce que c'est mon boitier qui
fait ça ou est-ce que c'est lui je ne
sais pas donc on va tester ça on va
regarder salade on peut se mettre déjà
un petit coup de hache des arts histoire
d'eux pour faire plaisir à voyager en
mode projet vidéo photo portrait là je
vais avoir un mode nuit 50 méga pixels
effets vidéo super moon dual vidéo qui
nous permet effectivement de voiliers
d'avoir d'un côté et de l'autre vous
pouvez venir filmer jusqu'à huit cas
regardez ici jusqu'à huit cas à 24
images par seconde et en 4k à 60 images
par seconde donc ça c'est cool alors là
je suis sur le professionnel et sérieux
de modèles voyez c'est la même chose
j'ai de la 8 cas à 24 et fait donc ça
c'est plutôt cool donc si vous voulez
vous amuser en vidéo ben vous avez
vraiment de quoi faire ici car dg
l'option super macro que je n'ai pas de
notre côté donc si je vais faire de la
super macro est bien là comme j'ai pas
un télémaque ronde un tel objectif je ne
peux pas en faire après de vous à moi on
s'en fiche un petit peu alors il ya
différents mode hd à noter l'afssa va
moi c'est le chien au micro focus avec
le suivi d'un mouvement avec le suivi
des yeux également et puis vous avez
quoi le motion qui a perdu tout sens le
regardera geoffrey plein de tests et
puis vous avez également du one click
cinéma donc assez intéressant à voir
aussi effectivement sur la partie vidéo
et puis le mode ultra night vidéo donc
on ira regarder tout savoir ce que ça
raconte réellement en termes de photos
et vidéos à savoir qu'ici vous avez du
wifi six wi fi 6e vous avez du nfc pour
le paiement dématérialisé double sim 5g
et puis on a un indice de réparabilité
de 7,9 sur 10 plutôt bien très
rapidement genou quelques photos que
j'ai prises avec le chiot me dosé puis
ensuite on regardera les chemins du scr
au regard des premières photos on
regarde un petit peu déjà entre le grand
angle l' ultra grand-angle et puis le
téléobjectif alors vous ne voyez ici ce
que vous voyez en fait tout ça et vous
le verrez sur les photos elles sont
assez assez orange jaune aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya eu une pluie de cause
d'un nuage du sahara donc il ya un peu
du sable partout ya une ambiance très
jaunâtre dans la vie donc c'est à dire
vraiment vraiment de ça ça vient pas du
tout de l'appareil on va être un peu
partout d'encre regardez ici à ces
traîtres et zone mais ça vient
réellement et bien de l'ambiance globale
de la vie donc on regardera dans le
texte ultérieurement si effectivement
ses genoux ces pages jaunes on aura d'un
petit peu on passe sur l'ultra grand
temps que c'est un petit peu point poils
jaunes je vous montre rapidement un pour
qu'on puisse se faire un petit aperçu
rapidement alors c'est saturé ça
fonctionne je trouve ça va plutôt bien
dans l'ensemble alors ça c'est une fois
de plus le chien ont mis 12 et on va se
regarder le chiot mis douze trotteurs la
macro une fois de plus c'est pas hyper
hyper fan on regarde ça rapidement parce
que autant sur l'écran ça passait sa
part et c'est beau ça paraissait être
net précis autant là ça ne l'est pas
alors j'ai une photo qui leva celle là
voyez la salle et au centre mais voilà
bon après c'est toujours un peu la même
chose sur les caméras de krautrock
mégapixels ont fait pas de la magie
royer ambiance très très jeunes
aujourd'hui ici à paris voilà donc c'est
vraiment un premier aperçu on peut pour
bien pas trop jouer parce que la qualité
va rapidement dégradée mais cinq fois
plus c'est pas anormal et ça me paraît
normal puisqu'en plus et si on n'a pas
de télé objectifs on est sur un capteur
micro de 5 mégapixels on voit pas est
très très loin le mode portrait du tour
pas trop mal même si c'est vrai qu'à
l'écran sans rendez pas compte mais une
fois que la photo est prise et bien je
trouve que les contours sont assez d'été
plutôt bien géré merci au stade rhein 8
jane douanes qui fonctionnent dans dc
bien regarder quelques photos comme
salah ben on fera ça marche c'est saturé
ça marche pas trop mal je ferais plein
d'autres photos parce que là il ya la
lumière est pas extraordinaire on se
rend pas trop compte il ya un côté un
peu de jaune c'est un peu saturé vert
ici on a du mal à se rendre compte donc
il faut que le ver ressort la beauté un
peu sursaturé ici au niveau du verre de
la revente ou qui ressent un petit peu
ça c'est souvent un traitement
controversé xiaomi donc à voir si c'est
la même chose lors du test ou tard hier
mans puis la caméra de cfi cadence un
peu 3 lys et met une fois de plus ça
c'est vraiment un effet shiomi qui vient
vraiment une lisse et les peaux pour
faire une peau toute douce toute belle
donc ça c'est vraiment le le truc qu'on
trouve aussi assez classiquement chez
chuo me voilà pour la partie à photos
sur le shérif 12 ils ont même fait un
dooly's ou alors si dans les effets
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver alors
regardez je me mets comme ça et je me
recule alors l'attendait hop là je vais
vous reculez plage fais gaffe à ce
qu'ils font au niveau recul on peut il
ya le monsieur derrière heureusement il
a vu donc là sans registre et vous allez
voir le résultat c'est regarder le
résultat du dooly's zoom je me refuse
bon il ya un côté un peu fake comme je
bouge sais pas où tu mets ça marche
c'est quand même assez assez marrante
c'est bon c'est bon t'es propre nom à la
bouche pas je te vois bien je te fournir
le gîte au visage l'âge et à forme recul
toit un peu pour voir recul toit
directoire dans les airs cultes
significativement en gros casse toi quoi
voilà là je te perds un peu si je zoome
je te récupère vas-y au revoir est-ce
que je peux jouer davantage x 10
x 10 6 snow x 5 a ajouté je t'ai je t'ai
ultra-grand-angle au nom de dieu non non
c'est bien reconnaissance du visage le
tracking la stab est là
qu est ce que tu as l'air heureux non ça
marche ça je suis bien la star des
bonnes feuilles des trucs pas mal parce
que je peux bien jouer un peu comme ça
là ah ouais
si si c'est pas mal j'ai pas mal à
garder un truc qui est assez marrant
c'est qu'en fait l'état la
reconnaissance boîte à un suivi un
tracking ça c'est leur nouveau truc là
c'est assez marrant et attend là je suis
comme ça si je pressens luttera
grand-angle non il n'ya plus sur le
grand-angle il l'avait et six biozones
et il le reconnaît et là c'est pas mal
ça pourrait peut-être faire des mises au
point donc il ya un truc qui est assez
rigolo ça c'est par les intrus
qu'approfondir
voilà maintenant des photos prises avec
le chien ont mis 12 pro alors on s'en
doutera pro on va un peu mieux c'est
plus sympa toujours dans l'esprit est
jeune mais ça c'est la journée qu'il le
veut donc une fois de plus laissé moi le
tc davantage et on en reparlera un peu
plus tard mais sinon dans l'ensemble sur
le papier c'est pas mal mais c'est vrai
que ce jeune peter un peu le truc qu'on
n'arrive pas trop à se rendre compte on
peut venir vous maison et mes bons rails
c'est un peu comme tout on va éviter à
lezoux mais trop près le traitement de
la peau et lycées mais je trouve un peu
mieux que sur le chien a omis 12 puis
voyez on a entendu travaux entend
toujours un peu saturé on le voit ici la
voyez au niveau du verre sur l'arbre et
sur la statue mais on a des effets qui
sont assez sympa par contre 1 voilà
voyez donc tout ça on confirmera et on
ne regardera plus tard c'est vrai il
faut commencer à vous montrer quelques
premières photos avoir un premier
ressenti mais le fait que ce soit
tellement j'en ai aujourd'hui ça bien un
peu tout je me foutais de très très près
un monsieur pigeon voilà
allez regarder danser un petit premier
test côté vidéo donc là c'est la caméra
de cette fiche en train de filmer
on va switch est maintenant derrière
alors il ya plein de modèles dual vidéo
alors le duel vidéo on voit la
différence à haut niveau les grands
niveau des caméras la voyais entre la
caméra de cette fille qui lie la caméra
derrière donc ça on peut le faire alors
il ya plein de petits modèles qui
existent à la nuit es6 annonçant le
verra lors du test meilleurs comme ça à
regarder sauf que pour l'instant le
rendu est plutôt pas mal salut toi ce
que je vois à l'écran c'est la loi sur
l'air le trouve très saturé par rapport
à ce que je joue en vrai regardez la
façon dont tout cela s'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus dé saturer et si jean rède
à l'arrière c'est tout de suite beaucoup
plus saturée à voir si c'est juste un
effet comme ça ou si c'est vraiment le
cas alors du traitement final je suis là
sur l' ultra grand-angle il ya aussi une
star électronique j'ai l'impression mais
ça fonctionne ça c'est plutôt bien aussi
de le voir comme sarah salut toi ça va
ça va tu me suis tu me suis-je été
finement ses films on s'est stabilisée
c'est pas mal et on peut également y
aller avec le téléobjectif suis en x 200
x de jeux de suite et c'est quand même
vachement bien stabilisé 1 regarde c'est
fou ils ont vraiment bien bossé là
dessus donc ok là dessus on est sur le x
2 et je peux monter jusqu'à 1 x x 5 x 6
je sais pas si c'est le max regarder se
tient une main arrachée tremble un peu
ça se voit j'essaie de le tenir à demain
pour ça est un peu mieux et c'est quand
même façon le fond alors il ya plusieurs
types de stabilisation celle là c'est
vraiment tout le plus light et je trouve
que ça marche plutôt bien voyez c'est
assez réactif lorsqu'on vient comme ça
et qu'on s'arrête ça marche
c'est
efficace efficace sans danger viendra
des aplats coucou on fait une salut coco
alors combien écouter smartphone parce
que c'est un peu le truc qui nous
intéresse le show midouze le chiot mis
12 g les prix la centrale je connais pas
par coeur le chiot midouze il coûte sur
la config 8 256 go de stockage 899 190
placées pour le ch a mis 12 et le modèle
professionnel celui là il coûte sur la
config 12 giga de ram 256 go de stockage
1099 euros 90 et il ya des précommandes
qui sont intéressantes et du 17 au 23
mars il ya des pré commandes avec une
montre offerte de shiomi c'est celle là
celle que vous avez regardé la sur
l'écran est bien les cadeaux allez pour
vous c'est la watch est ce qui coûte 2
169 euros 99 qui vous est offerte pour
l'achat d'un chiot midouze ou d'un chiot
midouze pro donc je vous mets tous les
liens en bas dans la description alesi a
faites vous plaisir et puis ils ont
également présenté une autre monde c'est
la s1 active qui à 199 euros 90 regarder
à la gouache et semble elle est quand
même hyper mignonne bracelet cuillère
bracelet plastique plus pour l'outdoor
et pour le sport est mignon ce style est
sympa comme ça c'est pas comme on vous
l'a trouvé ce que vous en pensez je
montais une petite image là on peut même
venir payer avec un essai magnifique on
n'arrête pas le progrès on peut venir
payer d'un voyage du nfc ça c'est plutôt
bien à vous les avez vous avez les
couleurs des bracelets c'est très
chouette voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire aujourd'hui commencer à vous
montrer un peu ses smartphones qui sont
arrivés le chiot midouze le xiaomi 12
pro 2 smartphones que je trouve
intéressant j'ai hâte de voir ce que ça
va donner réellement dans des conditions
de meilleure luminosité ou on n'aura pas
un ciel offre aujourd'hui dans paris
donc laissez moi un peu de temps car
plein de photos plein de vidéos jeux
tout tester vous donner mon retour
compétences et de smartphones et puis on
parlera également expérience logiciel
avec me white rsa sera aussi à tout
vraiment intéressant qui arrivera d'ici
quelques temps donc une fois de plus
abonné vous puissiez vous avez des
questions sur ses smartphones pose elle
est tout en bas en commentaire je
regarderai pour y répond pour vous
donner en tout cas des indices des
résultats répondre à vos questions et
tout vous dire dans la vidéo de test
voilà nous embrasse le soin de vous il
ya très vite et puis voilà de l'amour
qu'est ce qu'on va souhaiter on va
souhaiter de l'amour de l'amour de la
joie et de la félicité sur terre et puis
là-bas à bientôt
[Musique]